this is an American sweatshop they
flourished in the early 1900s when
people were desperate for work and since
there were no regulations on what they
had to pay they paid workers next to
nothing so the u.s. adopted something
that had already worked in other
countries a minimum wage this is a chart
of the minimum wage in the United States
over the past 60 years you can see how
it's gone up and up and up from $1 an
hour in 1960 to $7.25 today go America
right but this chart is actually pretty
misleading if you take the same line but
adjust it for inflation you'll see the
problem every time the minimum wage has
been raised inflation is dragged it
right back down really America's minimum
wage hasn't gone up it's essentially
stayed the same since the 80s what
you're seeing here this constant up and
down this is weird it's not how the rest
of the world does it and it leads to a
bunch of problems for American workers
and businesses but it doesn't have to be
this way the minimum wage sets the
smallest amount that a business anywhere
in the country can pay its workers each
hour but when that first bill became law
in 1938 it had one big problem that
first law didn't actually set any kind
of guidance on when and how you're
supposed to raise the minimum wage in
the future that meant that if the
minimum wage was going to go up Congress
would have to pass a new law that's what
these steps are but as we already know
they aren't occuring enough to keep up
with inflation and this system also
makes the u.s. minimum wage sort of
unpredictable look at this period
starting in 1997 the minimum wage sat at
$5.15 an hour for ten years then it was
raised in 2007 to $7.25 by 2009 cool but
that's a 40% increase in a pretty short
time after a decade of inaction how do
you plan for that if you own a business
not having that consistency does raise a
lot of problems for business owners will
they have to lay off employees will they
have to reduce work hours or will they
just raise prices on their customers
imagine how much smoother that could all
go if the minimum wage just kind of went
up over time well we don't have to
imagine it
in France they automatically raise their
minimum wage every single year they tie
it to inflation in the average salary of
a French worker in Australia a
commission reviews the minimum wage
every year considering economic factors
like inflation the UK also has a
commission made up of union business and
economic experts the Czech Republic's
Commission consults with employer and
union representatives their line is
lower overall than Americas but it's
still trends upwards same with Costa
Rica and their committee reviews the
minimum wage twice a year in most
countries the minimum wage is in the
hands of economic officials in the US
it's in the hands of politicians and
that goes about as well as you'd expect
today the federal minimum wage is a
poverty wage last thing we need are more
one-size-fits-all Washington mandates it
could eliminate up to 3.7 million jobs
it would lift 1.3 million Americans out
of poverty raise the wage for 33 million
people a quarter of the workforce those
wages are only available if you get
hired working people are doing their
jobs let us do ours republicans have
generally resisted increasing the
minimum wage they they tend to support a
lot of pro-business policies and
business leaders do not want minimum
wage increases Democrats on the other
hand they have a lot of support from
labor unions so they're the ones who
you're usually pushing for an increase
in the minimum wage so that's why
Congress rarely agrees on raising the
minimum wage and what makes America
system different than other countries
this chart shows how much a minimum wage
worker makes compared to the average
worker in every developed country with a
minimum wage all these countries have
some kind of commission or formula to
determine what the minimum wage should
be and they review it every year or two
and then there's the u.s. who does
neither and is dead last if the US had
done something similar like tie the
minimum wage to the average wage each
year we'd be here not amazing but not an
outlier what we're talking about is the
federal minimum wage which applies to
everyone who works in America but States
can set their own - and about half of
them currently have a higher minimum
wage than the federal one like
Washington State which in 1998 decided
to raise theirs every
single-year based on inflation sound
familiar
I mean it's a such a logical idea it's
done in other countries it really
doesn't make sense why it's not done at
the federal level like really it's just
about politics right now politicians are
yet again debating what the minimum wage
should be should it be fifteen dollars
eleven dollars or should it not be
raised at all but maybe the solution to
this never-ending the bait is to take
the decision out of politicians hands
[Music]
[Music]